the head of unlv breaks his silence
after a student died following a
fraternity boxing match it's a story our
i-team first broke and now the i-team
has the president's first interview
president keith whitfield sent an email
to the university community but he
hasn't answered questions until now
vanessa murphy has the story from campus
this is the first time unlv president
keith whitfield agreed to answer
questions about the fraternity boxing
match which ended with one student's
death this student was a part of our
family and we're actually you know
it's it's a little emotional for me to
even be thinking and talking about it
president whitfield says he talked with
nathan valencia's father to express
condolences valencia seen here in the
red headgear participated in this
fraternity boxing match on november 19th
he collapsed after the fight and died
four days later from head injuries
valencia's family points to a lack of
safety precautions like no paramedics or
professional medical help on standby and
a referee who they say was unlicensed
the i-team obtained this video where he
appears to be drinking alcohol the
family points out the event is a unlv
tradition and they say the university
and kappa sigma fraternity which held
the event are to blame what oversight
did the university have and what leaders
at the university did know this was
going to happen
that's one of the questions that we're
asking in this fact-finding uh
let's not call an investigation it's a
review of our procedures that we want to
go through
not only for this group but for all
programs on our campus
you mentioned a review is underway
but at this point as the leader of this
university who do you think should be
held accountable
well you know it's premature to say
exactly who we
want to
to start pointing fingers on about
accountability we're going to do a very
very thorough process and we're going to
make sure that we identify all the parts
and pieces of how this played out
on wednesday unlv announced the kappa
sigma fraternity is suspended the
valencia's family attorney tells me this
is a step in the right direction
reporting in las vegas vanessa murphy
live local now